insomma
fantasma
grida
ei siete tutti qua
bene farò fratello
guardate ci sono delle parole che ci fa
bene nel gioco di oggi dovremmo scappare
la delle barre
delle parole ci stanno esprimendo ma non
ci possiamo mangiare noi le banane farci
mangiare delle banane no in questo caso
saranno le banane a mangiarci si stanno
vendicando perché noi mangiamo
come non detto che figo abbiamo una
parola come zaino sì ma non ci ha
protetto dalle banane assassine che ci
hanno pensato ok finalmente finito
l'altro gioco e possiamo ricominciare
noi sono stati tutti mangiati dalle
banane vedrete con queste xvi perché
siamo infatti tutti fan giardino le
banane ma questa volta torneremo nel
gioco proveremo a noi a mangiare bene
noi proveremo
becca scappa non farci mangiare 70w
mohtaj una mappa che c'è operato
supermercato di due ma sono tantissime
non lo so e
non l'ho fatto in tempo va bene ma non
c'è baccata anche a k riappare preparati
si comincia ecco
nasconditi le uscite scopriranno presto
22 ott abbiamo nascondersi a un
nascondino modugno ba non esiga te non
avrei mai pensato che avremmo fatto una
scritta contro l'atalanta ci
vorrà un po il gioco del topo vi
ricordate
o no perché mondo anche se sono una
banana fa paura lo spiego io mi sono
nascosto proviamo passare da fa vuoi
sapere dove mi sono nascosto
[Musica]
avrei dovuto indovinarlo abitare per
porto di nasconde in cucina ma scusa
sono entrato ho visto un piatto con una
fetta di tosto detto che fai così sono
tanti pezzi di torta in giro e
catalogati a prender belle epoque quindi
posso uscire a prenderne altri allora sì
ma non farsi mangiare dalla banana e ho
trovato una monetina barabba ma sei tu
questa sì vabbè non poco la volatilità è
mia solo in cucina quindi
sono qui io l'ho nascosto
ma non è capitato ma scordiamoci passato
dove siamo un ristorante che cos'è
questo vediamo che cosa ci aiuti che ha
fatto molto bene questo gioco mi piace
un sacco
di una fantasma
aspettavo ho trovato no che congo ho
trovato una vetrina piena di paranà
ma non credo che si possano prendere poi
sarebbero è vero ancora di più le mani
giganti magari sono i loro beni
ok mi sono nascosto ma
sono stato il colmo biglietto lì e mi
farei nel fatto che dobbiamo scappare da
dare ma è comunque pauroso come gioco a
voi ovviamente non so che un bel mi
piace qualcosa perché se questo video
raggiunge il 5 mila mi piace però una
seconda parte in cui scappiamo dalle
banane e meloni banca o no no no no non
so scrivere
[Musica]
mancavano solo 40 stefano ti avrei
potuto vincere
nella chat e qualcuna dice anita files
alleno io ho capito bene ogni tanto si
riconosce te è
stato sinistra vincerà ho penato ma non
sono beccato il vero mangiamo qualcosa
ma io voglio sapere come cazzo di liceo
che l'auto
non effettivamente la neo
supermercato si sa chi ha vinto il
supermercato di abyan andiamo a mangiare
questo ipermercato pieno di banano e mi
dispiace per te ci sono domanda ho
trovato una torta come si fa a perdere
la porta allora io mi sono nascosta come
questo armadietto è passata la banana e
non mi ha visto in giro a poco credo che
la tecnica migliore sia nascondersi bene
e ti vedo chi invece le strade
soprattutto la mole vive e ma cosa serve
il nostro zainetto 6 a qualche super
potere che ha preso no non
ci cado mi hai fatto perdere loro sono
lì a circa da per terra lo sai ok
attento sì l'ho vista sto scappando
il gioco del tuo aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto non mi hanno preso di nuovo che ha
preso mi manca ancora un pollicino forse
se lo faccio da rai 2 minuti e poi dice
che fra poco le uscite saranno aperte
dobbiamo andare alle uscite a scappare
subito e questo un puzzle vitale è stato
mangiato
dispiace vitali conferma mangiato e mi
ricorda anche il gioco del serpente nome
del mio figlio non segnava scappare dal
serpente però a volte eravamo noi i
serpenti in casa che speriamo di
capitare banane perché sono più una
scusa penso che ti ha visto
benissimo assoluta perché sono ancora
viva che ne presentiamo pullicino nei
tre ma sapevo di avere tre vite c'è
quindi le parole possono entrare dentro
gli armadietti la seta palamara ma c'è
palco si è caduto poverino
non ormai viabilità
come un pulcino il nostro cugino sarà
ancora inseguendo
ma poi
abbiamo perso di nuovo
dai dobbiamo guadagnarsi più riuscire a
scappare dalle banane
vediamo se riusciamo capitare noi banale
perché una di rincorrere vitale da
banana il gigante se
mettiamo
insieme roca pari diritti e li metterò
subito per prima se volete entrare a far
parte dell'atto ai
3.000 attivata la campanella e prendete
il mio libro non potete
trovate nel link già scritto la trovate
che preveda la trovate su amazon insomma
vi piacerà tantissimo
fateci sapere qual è la lettura
preferita
per la scuola che adesso a fare in
inglese tra scuola penati ha
votato perché se la scuola delle banane
ben a
teheran
aspettiamo
siamo di nuovo in quella sorta di
cos'è un un'area giochi anche se ancora
faccio lo
pensavo di essere la banana invece no ma
questa è la banana talento arrivato come
già arrivata
e ancora la mia vita passata davvero e
la quale viaggiava con gli occhi rossi
come la più inquietante di tutti è
andata di qua
[Musica]
tranquilla tranquilla andato avanti sono
in cucina
e l'app inquietante la banana gialla con
gli occhi rossi dai dobbiamo resistere
ancora otto minuti un po ma io mi annoio
stare nascosti buona pure le corna
staccati dai tutte io ho risolto questo
puzzle dell'aiuto mi amor mio marito il
mio tutto curino ok sto facendo questo
passo non per lo cedette
aver completato
sempre preso un altro moresino no sei
stato presto dalla banana con no adesso
si guida è stato mai stata perché io
sono così schiappa questo gioco manca
solo un minuto
dove si permette in due tipo non manca
così poco
si sopravvissuto
prossima partita da riley cioccolato di
cioccolato ma
siamo felici
e allora palestra vedete questa è la
palestra scappiamo sottoscriverle schema
queste strade sono chiuse sono gli
spalti non sono le scale non può esserci
solo la pala è per questo liceo
di qui come baciare il culo
ma non amo gli occhi verdi
io ho rotto o biblioteca
cosa ci facesse lì c'è il sensore rosso
qui quindi potrebbe essere con vicino
lei e quando il sensore il sensore
dietro il dott
quando il rosso può dire che picchia in
a adesso è bianco quindi vuol dire che
lontana banana è andato anche more
abbiamo visto che quando è andata alla
frutta
si è costata dove male
ok vediamo adesso massimiliano della
spazzatura dai
ma dove siamo a noi siamo un
supermercato
questo è il posto preferito visto sito è
stato progettato per sempre supermercato
penso sia infection questo
bene allora ancora vedi per mentre
onu che mi è apparso il simbolo della
morte la banana è stata rallentata anche
perché ho messo il pezzo di torta
quando con frey che si quando completi
un pezzo di puzzle la banana si rallenta
ancona dove una parola strane tipo
l'ombra marcia con un cappello
[Musica]
pronto sono diventato la banana fare una
banana gialla che certi versi
focarina questa banana e ora andiamo a
cercare un
dato
così tante bolle perché sei modalità
fantasma forse no no non sono un
fantasma si cosi stretti annuncia stata
quindi sei tu una banana e adesso le
capisco come marito
non sono diventato una banana a kyoto
dovete che bella terra la squadra gialla
racconta che banale già allora possiamo
avvicinarci alle banane nel prendere
paura c'è chi proprio quella che carina
questa bharara ha in testa un cappello
con un albero in fiore ma non
dimentichiamoci di anita banalità
acqua o la bara nata tabù è troppo cari
non mi interessa cercare gli altri
giocatori perché mi diverto troppo come
ben sa le cose se sì cosa prendere gli
altri giocatori ma sono le vittima però
anche se sei lentini sono in convento si
può essere una mente ho subito da
corridoi
locatore nascosto dove sei troveremo non
ci credo che stiamo 10 baraggia
casco di banane
dieci secondi no non ci credo la prima
volta che sono una banana e perdo non è
postina molto giocatore super bravo
allora
proviamo banana spaccata no ha vinto
scappare di suo
eccoci qua davvero uno dei posti
preferiti da tutti sia questo centro di
una cosa già ti interrompo ma c'è
scritto presto
ridotta
anche intento non ti azzardare a
cercarmi
[Musica]
nel frattempo dicci come essere banana è
bellissimo
dovrei mangiare qualcuno ancora non
trovato nessuno però posso sabotarli
anch'io
i puzzle quindi vediamo vediamo dove
dall'altra parte se qualcuno qui chi è
questa chi è questo voglio sapere chi è
questo ancora non è mirato a nessuno
scappano tutti ho preso qualcuno ho
preso qualcuno
[Applauso]
un momento ad una vita già nappi che mi
dedicherò quando sarà una banalità ma
io non sto mangiando cucchetto perché
non scappa allora l'ho visto a nico
meno male sei lento come malati un morso
milan avanti vedere cosa una
gioventù ed è in forse ora posso
scappare
dove era riuscito e fuggito ma bastate
scappando non ci credo e penso che siamo
capaci
mancate devo riuscire a prenderti allora
dove siete le uscite sono qui poco
riuscita o sono una vita però io so
dov'è l'uscita e che spettano qui
ma non c'è neanche l'ombra visitare
con calma
quando la malavita o fuggito no ma non
eri lì non si che la parte sbagliata
ovvero l'uscita solo che ho visto un
altro giocatore
no non ci credo però sia più riusciti a
fuggire io ho perso evento bere un po
lento come banale e poi non sapevi
dov'era l'uscita tre mandati non ero lì
solo che ho visto qualcuno che stava
scappando ho detto adesso provo a
mangiarlo anche se no mi ha ingannato e
dove andiamo allora vediamo l'ora che
l'avevo visto ancora meno romano si
farebbe l'insalata delle banane
ragazzi sono io la banana
ok
il momento di scappare vitale perché
penso che realizza si vendicherà perché
le otto tigri
telefono andare a mangiare
[Musica]
e sono pure a casa mia andiamo mandarci
tutto questo giocatore ehi
ma non è morto
devi mordere tre volte oi quadri no
vabbè ci sono i quadri a tutti con le by
laura truffaut bella questa casa luther
king air ha detto sto tempo barone vai
mai banale incorniciato
così vicino
a te la scotto in quelle sui passaggi
segreti a prendervi scene zona
no no non c'è nessuno come di altri
emerso che stiamo facendo in squadra un
sacco di puzzle è quindi riuscita
riusciremo a scappare di
nuovo perché avete tra vita è troppo
difficile per una banana mangiato
troppo filo 20 ma si bellissima per
scoperto questo gioco
non qualcuno devono prenderlo nuovamente
come fai a prendere tutti questi è se il
problema è che non ci sara una partito
news o no
spesso qualcun'altro un'altra volta e
ora mi manca l'ultima vita
prima
che tu sei
[Musica]
ei sette cose qua
bene vai fratello
ora controllo riuscita vediamo se vi
azzardate alla vicina via d'uscita è la
cosa importante che mi sono allontanato
da te finalmente si è rimangiata
immobile casinò potete a scappare
perché ci sono io che mi aspetta
capitano troppo bravo
zaia che io ho mangiato un po di persone
tra gli over dose pochi non si creda che
mi è scappata ubicata tra
l'altro conservato tutti e tre i
cuoricini quindi non sei riuscito mai
capitati a
8 secondi
5 4 3 2
qualcuno è fuggito o scaduto il tempo
ma essere anche
se volete in facciamo un altro episodio
lasciato beh mi piace qui sotto è ora vi
lasciamo con altre famiglie a pubblicare
per vedere i nostri altri video al catas
quella che preferite buona visione
[Musica]
a